闇なこんにちはエー
肇社長だよ
今日は君たちにとって大きなアプリを紹介しようと思ってるんだ
興味たち7号京都知ってるか何かをが遅い広告とかでよく観てね結構話題のアプリ
らしいんだけど
なめこな午後何が5個7
えっ
やっぱりわかんなかった後755
707575アナザーデイ夏ねちょっと取り乱したよて75校っていうアプリです
持ってもじゃあねやってます
今75っていうのは簡単に言えばるですねラインとがツイッターみたいな感じの新しい
タイプというか僕ないってみた感じなんていうんだろう line とかツイッターの
間みたいなイメージでした
755のまあ特徴としてはまあ人気なアーティストとか有名人とか惚れとか
すいませんです有名人のか著名人アーティストとかのこのトークを実際に見たりその
トークに例えばそれを見てる普通の人とかもう誰でもフィンガーがそのトークに対して
こうコメントができたり字有名人のアーティスだけとかじゃなくて自分たちだけでも
遠くのグループをねこう作ったりできるっていう新しいタイプの sns みたいな
感じだと思ってもらっていいと思いますよ実際に見ていこうと
思います4日にというかめっちゃ簡単です多分僕が言うまでもなくすぐ登録できるので
ぜひやってみてください
ベネ755あでラインとが twitter と facebook とかで広角さん
とかも出来るんで
他の sns との連携機能も充実しておりますこういうね
只今更新中ってもう更新してる人もいるんですよはいここに僕のアレがあります遠く
です
5公式になってるんだよきなまあこういう感じで僕が江東区でつぶやくのみんなが見れ
るっていう
例えばこの例という人がれいちゃんがいつも youtube 見てるって言ったら俺
がありがとう
その返事はみんなが見れるみたいな
この花を見るともらういろんな人がオイラに言えばコメントを飛ばしておりこれで
いろんな人がまぁオイラに野次馬コメントともするとこれでオイラがもう g に反し
てますどーもーん
こういう匂いだが自分に完成というとそしたらみんながそこの遠くを見てるってみんな
がこれを見る
何だろうなんかおいらのイメージ的には超大勢がたラインみたいな超巨大ないっ的な
イメージでぜひ
を笑顔ならない高校の遠くに遊びに来てくださいませ7分後から一般たかおっしゃると
かいろいろあるんですよ
これは一般のして2人でもできます恋いろんな人
統計が実際に見れて一緒に話せるというやつですね
ちょっと誰かのところにちょっと書いてみましょうかねうわぁこれ銀2あぶねえなあ
もし見られたらどうしよ
微妙の山率という止め強いほらすぐプレミアはさんはいろんな人にちょっと返事をして
くれてるんですよ
フォローしましょう
フォローしちゃったじゃないか
やばいぞやばいです写真のコメントだ
でえっどうすればしわけじゃないその緊張する服今日は来られないんだよ
二素地
止めや[ __ ]たよねぇじゃねえねえやめこうやってね
アイドルのトークにもねバーンで言ってるんですよそしたらきゅっとしたらアイドルと
話せるかもしれんがヤバいヤバいヤバいヤバいヤバいヤバいヤバいヤバい
汗から世界ですか怖いなぁを1次元2するが
俺の10日もある人気トークに
そういう話ではないそんなことじゃないんだこれは緊張してんだ
もしこれで返事が入ってきたらこれはもうアイドルと投句者みたいになるからね帰って
きてほしい自分と帰って来て欲しくない自分がこう
戦っている感じですねまあお金や
みんな可愛いナースと和美さんもフォローしています何風邪ひいてんの
ヤバイぞ山々たったった太一を大丈夫ですか
いません
ちょっとずつの低迷ので止めは
やばいやばいやばいやばいやばいいややばくねぇは良いはこれがある
いいんだよ俺はねちゃんと話ししたいかねおやすみなさい
こういう感じでねまぁ混じりが j を普段そんな果たせないような人と来実際にお話
ができるっていう
ちょっと特殊なエッセイ ns というかアプリでございますまいとーくが4つになっ
てるこれ俺が話したってことが今までん
これで10日が作れるのか誰かとトークも作れたりします
そうそして俺が好きなのはこのスタンプなんですよこのなんか変な緑色息持ちの皆好き
だな
これは俺のし心の不安を表していたスタンプです
例えば本人が返すんで確実に帰ってこないかも住んでその本人ぐみーたコメントに多分
返していると思うので入って来てくださいお願います
なるほどな
カズミンさんはたぶん夜に行ってますね米によく返しています
この時間見る限り返せ時間が決まっているんですよね
皆さん忙しいと思うのでカズミンさんとも帰ってこないんだこの方はため夜によく回数
人です七瀬はあるさんも基本的には夜だな
偶力返してますね普通に夕方なんだよだめだつって帰って来ないかもしれない
結構ばらつきがありますねほゆみおなさんはチャンスがあれば多分堀未央奈さんぐらい
かなって感じです
時間的にね投稿を返してもらうためにはちゃんとその開始陶酔筆頭がどれぐらいの時間
よく変身するかっていうのをしっかり研究する必要がありますそれが僕が送った3人は
ねちょっとこんな時間から多分あんまり返してないんで帰ってくる見込みがこの時間に
はな
いいです
ねぇはいというわけでいかがでしょうか755
有名ちょっと話した一言気味そして俺と話した一言気味
造船に乗っちゃった親のトクホ路線一緒に下がりましょう以上75の紹介でした
じゃん
75ってアプリ知ってるんじゃない
なんか sns みたいなあるの
なんか芸能人とかとお願いしてるっていうラインみたいだったはじめもそれ変身するが
生んだけど俺はですねじゃあ簡単だけど
あああ